[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, I'm Nick Butcher, an
engineer on the Android
Developer Relations team.
And I'm here today with a design
byte to talk to you
about the fundamentals of
responsive design and how to
employ them in your Android
application design.
So Android is not a
one-size-fits-all OS.
It comes in many different sizes
and shapes, from small
phones to large tablets,
TVs, and beyond.
The great news is that Android
has been built from the ground
up to embrace this variety and
give you tools in order to
deal with it.
So from the very beginning,
Android has allowed you to
scale your user interface
up and down
between different devices.
The problem is that scaling
approaches will
only get you so far.
So I'm going to take you through
some of the common
pitfalls we see with this
relying on scaling approaches,
and then I'm going to go through
some alternative ways
of dealing with this.
So the first problem we see
commonly is one of having
excessive line lengths.
So in this application, the text
and images are running
the full width of the
device's screen.
On a smaller phone-sized device,
this might be fine.
But as you get beyond a certain
size, this becomes
uncomfortable.
Especially when you're looking
at lines lengths of text, you
want to be aiming for between
45 and 75 characters of text
in order to maintain a
comfortable reading experience
so the user can easily
can across it.
In this application, we can
see that this is clearly
exceeding that.
The next problem we commonly
see is one
of unbalanced content.
So in this example, we can see
there's a lot of content
clustered up in the top left
of the screen, and then
leaving huge amounts of
white space across
the rest of the screen.
This leads to a very unbalanced
feeling, which
makes your application feel
completely unoptimized for
this device.
And the last problem we commonly
see is more of a
missed opportunity almost of not
making the best use of the
real estate available to you.
So in this example, we might
have an application which
shows many photos.
And as we can see, these tiny
little thumbnails are all
grouped over to one side.
It really is a shame not to make
use of these beautiful
big screens when all this
extra real estate is
available to you.
So you want to be
avoiding this.
So these are some of the common
pitfalls we see in
relying on scaling approaches.
And the answer to dealing with
these problems really is to
adopt a responsive mobile
design to respond to the
device's characteristics.
So here are three techniques
you can use
in order to do this.
So the first technique is simply
one of combination.
This is, if you have extra room,
combining things from
different screens onto a single
screen in order to fill
up the space.
So in this example, we've got a
typical master detail view,
which on a phone would be
on two separate screens.
So clicking through from a list
item, for example, might
show subsequent details.
On a larger device with
sufficient width, we might
show both of these
things at once.
This will avoid the problem of
having those excessive line
lengths and make better use
of the screen real estate.
The second technique is one
that we call Macro Reflow.
So this is taking the major
building blocks of your
application and reflowing them
or rearranging them on the
screen in order to make better
use of the space.
So in this example, we simply
move something like a large
header image and the body
text, instead of being
vertically stacked above each
other, to be horizontally
stacked next to each other.
So this will give the image
more space to show off the
larger amount of screen real
estate as well as avoiding
those excessive line
lengths when it's
in a landscape device.
So this is not only useful for
different-sized devices, you
can also use this kind of trick
when changing on the
same device between different
orientations.
And the last technique I want to
go through is something we
call Micro Reflow.
So this technique really focuses
on the individual
blocks within your design, and
it delegates responsibility to
those individual blocks to
optimize themselves given a
certain amount of space.
So a couple examples
of doing that--
on the left here, we have a list
type application which,
given sufficient space, might
lead to those excessive line
lengths or very unbalanced
views.
So instead of that, each
individual list item knows
that given a certain amount of
space how to draw itself.
So once it gets over a certain
size, a certain amount of
width available to the device,
It'll change its
representation.
Instead of being a list item,
it might change to, say, a
grid representation.
So this will allow you to
fill the space better.
The second example is if there
is simply no way to introduce
more content, you
can introduce a
margin point instead.
So in this form type application
on the right, when
we go beyond the phone and
past a certain size, when
there just isn't any more
content we can show on screen,
we simply introduce a margin
point so it doesn't end up
being excessively long or
excessively unbalanced.
So those are just a few
techniques that you can employ
in your design of our
applications.
Over the rest of this series,
I'm going to go through some
DevBytes, which is going to
teach developers out there how
to actually build
these layouts.
Thanks very much.